[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
cloud sql can help you save time in
developing your next great app
cloud sql is a fully managed relational
database service from mysql postgres or
sql server
on google cloud it lets you hand off
mundane time consuming tasks like
patches updates backups and replicas
so you can focus on building your app
cloud sql integrates with bigquery for
analytics or can act as a back end to
your app engine compute engine or
kubernetes apps
setting up cloud sql is quick and
seamless in a snap you can create an
instance with the cloud console by
choosing the type of database version
and location
or use the g-cloud command line and then
you're ready to upload your data or
connect your applications
to go further set up automatic backups
replication
and failover so you can create a highly
available database for critical
applications
you get full encryption at rest in
transit keeping your private data
safe and compliant external connections
can be encrypted
using ssl or cloud sql proxy being a
relational database cloud sql is great
for oltp where frequent queries and
fast response times are needed so you
can use it to manage everything from a
single wordpress blog to a global
aggregation of wheat crops and rainfall
next time you're looking for a quick
relational database solution take a
minute to try out cloud sql
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
[Music]
sql
you